what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and the new arc in the
seven deadly sins story is here in a big
way some brand new plot points have just
been revealed and things are gearing up
for another major multifaceted showdown
that will involve Mellie Otis Elizabeth
and the rest of the sins against the
demon king and his forces we have
learned a lot about where the story will
be heading next and that is exactly what
I will be discussing right now if you
enjoyed the seventh at least sense
content on this channel you can leave a
like to let me know and if you're new to
anime up or don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell and of
course I will be discussing the latest
twists and turns in the seven deadly
sins stories so spoiler alert manga
spoilers ahead you have been warned as
chapter 312 of the manga begins the sins
have already realized that bond and
meliodas did not succeed in defeating
the demon king as they initially thought
they now all know that the demon king
managed to survive somehow that he found
another vessel and that he restored the
curse that had been placed on Elizabeth
if that wasn't enough natural disasters
continue to rain down on Britannia as a
result of melioidosis continued presence
in the mortal plane and the latest
culprit that is destroying the farms and
houses of the kingdom is giant hail with
this the stories once again reminding us
that Melly Otis was supposed to leave
the mortal plane and enter the demon
realm and the fact that he still hasn't
is going to have real consequences
meanwhile the demon king inside Salvas
body whips up some fancy new digs for
himself and prepares to exact his
revenge on meliodas
elizabeth and the sins as he is testing
out the strength of his new vessel the
demon king says that zelgius his body is
performing smoothly and better than he
had expected the demon king had been
worried that zelda's body would not be
able to perform as well as the body of
Melly Otis but apparently zelgius is
also strong enough to allow the demon
king to use his full potential but the
demon king is going to need some time to
gain complete control of the vessel as I
predicted in last week's video about the
shocking return of zeldron
the demon king has learned his lesson
from the epic battle against meliodas
and the others he now realizes how
strong the sins are and he is not about
to underestimate them again in the
previous video I said that the demon
king might summon the powerful Endora
monsters from the demon realm in order
to help him deal with the sins and that
is exactly what he does in this chapter
the demon king knows that now that
Elizabeth's curse has been restored the
sins will find his whereabouts
eventually so he uses the gate that
Merlin had made earlier in order to
summon a massive Endura beast from the
demon realm now the gate that Merlin had
opened was only big enough for a human
to pass through and there was never any
real danger of a powerful demon entering
this realm through the gate but the
demon king uses his own power to tear
the gate open and summon an enduro the
very manifestation of destruction and
death the sins can instantly sense what
is happening and they decided go thermal
and King the N and bond will deal with
the Endura while Mel Yodas and Elizabeth
face off against the demon king poor
hawk and Eska nor are tasked with
informing King Batra and the rest of the
kingdom about what is happening which is
not the most glorious task to say the
least but hey what can you do because
Elizabeth's curse is back meliodas has
to protect her and he cannot let her out
of his sight which means that the two of
them must stay together and face the
demon king together meanwhile meliodas
and Elizabeth are fully aware that the
demon King's new vessel is zelgius but
meliodas does not tell the rest of the
sins about this he says that this is
between him his brother Zell drous and
their old man the demon king and he
doesn't want to involve anyone else when
she decides to come with him Elizabeth
hands meliodas his sacred treasure the
demon sword lost vein now to be honest
I've never really considered melioidosis
sacred treasure to be that important it
played an important role in defeating
the Endura from the prisoners of the sky
seven deadly sins movie but other than
that lost vein never really seemed to be
like an essential item for meliodas
however we will see if now in this new
arc lost Wayne will actually play a more
central role perhaps some new different
powers and abilities related to lost
vein will be revealed the fact that
Elizabeth makes it a point of returning
the sacred treasure to meliodas at this
time seems significant to me
and I do expect the lost lane will play
some role in the story in the near
future the chapter ends with Mellie Otis
and Elizabeth flying off together to
save zelgius and we get another
beautiful moment between them that gives
us further insight into why these two
fell in love with each other in the
first place
Mellie Otis says to Elizabeth you've
always held my hand and been by my side
you've pushed me and given me courage
you were my light it's all those things
about you that made me fall in love with
you and I really can't overstate how
much I feel that Elizabeth's character
has developed as we've learned more and
more about her she clearly had such a
massive impact on Mellie Otis and his
life for thousands of years and their
love is an inspirational one the human
reincarnation of Elizabeth starts off as
a pretty simple and basic character if
we're being honest but Elizabeth as a
whole including her complete character
arc spanning over a hundred lives is
definitely an excellent and fascinating
character my takeaway from this chapter
is that we are gearing up for a massive
showdown one that will be even bigger
than the previous battle against the
demon king by summoning the Endura
and perhaps even more than one Endora
the demon king shows us that he has
learned his lesson and he has no
intention of fighting meliodas Elizabeth
and the other sins on his own the demon
king has two major factors working in
his favor first
Mellie Otis is not supposed to be here
he was supposed to return to the demon
realm and every extra moment that he
spends in the mortal plane brings about
more disaster and destruction to
Britannia it is only a matter of time
before meliodas begins to feel too
guilty to remain here because he doesn't
want innocent people to suffer so in
this sense the demon king has time on
his side
second Elizabeth's curse has now
returned so at any moment Mellie Otis is
going to have to pay close attention to
Elizabeth in order to keep her safe this
means that Mellie Otis cannot be fully
focused on the battle against the demon
king because he will constantly be
looking over his shoulder for any
potential threat to Elizabeth this is an
additional thing that meliodas has to
worry about and this certainly works in
the demon King's favor
however the demon king also has to
factors working against him first as he
said himself he will need more time to
gain complete control of his new vessel
so if malleolus and Elizabeth can
locate him right away is possible that
the demon king won't be able to face
them at full power
second the real Zell dress is still
there inside his own body and the love
of his life gelda is also out there
somewhere we saw that in the previous
battle Mele Otis was able to resist the
demon Kings control from the inside and
especially after Elisabeth and the
others were allowed to speak to him
through golfers and evasion ability so
theoretically the demon king may face a
similar issue with celtris if the real
Zell dress is able to regain
consciousness on the inside and if he
realizes that gelda has been released
from the seal and is out there looking
for him Zell drous may be able to resist
the demon Kings control long enough for
meliodas to defeat him I expect that
this arc will bring sell justice
character development to the next level
as he struggles between his loyalty to
his father the ruler of the demon clan
and his desire to be with gelda and
changed a demon realm for the better his
desire to rule in a more fair and more
harmonious way than his father has ruled
I also expect that the battle will
spread to include all of our favourite
characters in one way or another
not just the sins and I'm expecting to
see my L in the one mode and also
Eskin or potentially getting sunshine
back so that he can once more be a
useful member of the team at any rate I
am certainly glad that the story didn't
just end as abruptly as it seemed that
it would and I'm happy that the
complicated relationship between Mele
Otis celtris and their father is going
to receive further development I can't
wait to see what happens next let me
know what you guys think are you excited
for this new art and how do you think
that the battle is going to unfold is
the demon king going to summon just one
Endora or a whole bunch of them is he
going to face meliodas head-on or is he
going to hide out and bite his time
until he gains complete control of his
new vessel and what role is gelda going
to play in all of this let me know down
in the comments if you enjoyed the seven
deadly sins content on this channel and
you want to see more you can leave a
like to let me know and if you're new to
anime uproar please don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
also don't forget to check out our brand
new bond love the pain and Eska Noir all
hail Diwan shirts on anime out Broadcom
a huge thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons for supporting our
work on when I especially thank our pro
hero tier patrons the one and only
Gilgamesh keel on and chubs is the man
and another huge thank you to our the
one to your patrons the ones who stand
above all other glands including
ace Maddy Mac James a Lola madam Ingrid
ah and Ahmad and at the very pinnacle of
interdimensional greatness the tier
reserved only for legends a massive
thank you to baby ray the first-ever
disciple of Lord to ego himself if you
guys feel that our content provides
value for you and you want to support
more be sure to check out our patreon
link in the description even donating a
single dollar will give you access to
our anime up for patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching I really appreciate it and
until next time see us space cowboys
[Music]